hey I think you'll find this hilariously
compelling Donald Trump as many of you
know has been accused of varying degrees
of sexual assault by a variety of women
and girls the number depending on how
you categorized them could be 12 it
could be 26 depends on where you draw
the line in terms of assault
Donald Trump has versus just harassment
to be clear Donald Trump has done
everything possible to shut these women
up he's hired high-priced lawyers he's
used payoffs of six figures in
combination with non-disclosure
agreements he's intimidated and
threatened women the entire thing Joe
Biden is also accused of sexual assault
by a woman most recently known as Tara
Reid I guess is the way I would say it
Joe Biden has asked that a file search
take place for her name in a number of
different files to see if there's a
record of this allegation from 1993 so
Donald Trump's daughter-in-law
Larry Trump an advisor to the 20/20
campaign if you can believe that goes on
Fox News's judge Jeanine Pirro show and
says with a straight face if you were
innocent you would do anything possible
to clear your name including opening up
files irony is dead my friends take a
look at this video well I would think if
if you were being accused of something
and you were totally innocent you would
go to any lengths possible judge to try
and clear your name including allowing
people to open up files like that and
make sure you turned over every single
leaf to prove your innocence and and
make sure that people understood that
these charges were false and that you
did nothing wrong so apply what she says
to Donald Trump if Trump is innocent he
would do anything possible to open the
files to prove his innocence
except from paid to close the files as
usual the rules apply to everyone but
Trump himself there is a whole long list
of Donald Trump's accusers to whom this
strategy could be applied and yet it's
not it's the opposite not opening files
paying to keep files closed using
non-disclosure agreements to shut women
up every tactic you can imagine now if
judge Jeanine Pirro were a serious
journalist or even just
commentator who wants to be taken
seriously
she should have immediately said to
Larry Trump why didn't Donald Trump do
that when it came to his 26 accusers why
hasn't Donald Trump opened the files on
anything or released women from
non-disclosures but Judge Jeanine is not
a serious person but remember that lara
trump's audience is Trump himself and
the Fox News crowd they don't care about
the hypocrisy they don't care about the
double standard and when presented with
the allegations against Trump they don't
care they are not reachable we've
learned that over the last four years
they're hypocrites and full of it but it
doesn't matter when your own followers
won't hold you to account why even
bother being consistent they're telling
the truth there's no reason to and while
we're at it this applies to Donald
Trump's taxes as well remember oh yeah I
plan to release them well now I'm under
audit so I'll released them when I'm not
it's been four years guys it's been five
years I think since he started talking
about whether he would release those tax
returns he's not going to be held
accountable by his supporters either so
it's up to up to us to do it in November
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blinka
stinketh lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
non-fiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free
get 25% off a subscription when you go
to blink is comm slash Pakman I've put
the link right underneath this video